thank you so much to the Academy for
putting on this event
and for supporting all of us emerging
filmmakers the whole week has been so
incredible and I've met so many really
talented people so thank you for the
effort that it takes to put on an event
like this thank you to the faculty at
AFI you have been so inspiring and
you've really pushed me to grow as a
filmmaker I really am grateful to that
thank you also to my fellow classmates
some of you are on stage with me and
thank you to my parents for encouraging
me to pursue my passions in life thank
you to the cast and crew who worked so
hard to bring this home to life
especially all these folks here I'm
gonna read a couple names Kate Joe
Morris Robert Nachman Robert Aguirre
Celinda Zhou Russell Bost Michael urban
Ryan Cutrona Travis hammer Alexandre
gray and the lead of Miller and son
Jesse James Keitel in telling a story
centered around a transgender character
it was really important for me to have
authenticity in the casting and I
couldn't be more grateful to share this
experience with Jesse Jesse this film
wouldn't have been nearly as impactful
without all of your talent so thank you
I made this movie because I wanted to
explore the feeling of
compartmentalization
I am gender non-binary and because my
identity is one that's not widely
understood I often find myself
confronted with the choice of whether to
speak up or to stay silent whether or
not you identify as transgender or
gender non-conforming I think everyone
can relate to the experience of wanting
to belong in the world I'm sure everyone
in this room has your own stories about
masking feelings in order to fit in to
move ahead or to protect yourself with
Miller & Son I was interested in looking
at the compromises people are faced with
on the path toward authenticity so thank
you again to the Academy for championing
all of our stories and for allowing us
the space to share the stories that mean
so much to us thank you
[Applause]